bon
[Musique]
on sent un peu chez babouchka loubat
c'est comme ça que tout le monde
l'appelle ou lac baïkal et elle est
vraiment une légende
elle vit seule elle 79 ans elle
représente vraiment le temps ti cité des
lacs le grandi ici elle le défend et se
bat pour l'environnement là on roule
littéralement sur le lac qui se
transforme en autoroute de glace géante
durant les mois d'hiver aujourd'hui fait
- et 34 mille soleils les conditions
sont idéales donc on savoir rencontrer
ma bouche trou
[Musique]
on nous voit elle chante à la gloire de
baykal qui est vraiment un joyau c'est
un loft qu'on appelle la mère sacré est
juste en face lille dolleren et c'est là
qu'on s'en va pour voir comment les
touristes longtemps accaparés et les
conséquences sur l'environnement
[Musique]
ban
où
[Musique]